a sibling is one thing most chinese  children don't have  that could change now at least in  families in which one parent grew up as  an only child  until now couples could only have a  second child if both parents were only  children  china introduced its one child policy in  1979  in an effort to slow the growth of its  population  the reforms were announced in beijing  after a four day meeting  of communist party leaders  they also decided to abolish china's  system of re-education labor camps  where tens of thousands of people are  interned without trial  initially set up to punish critics of  the communist party  the camps are often used by officials to  imprison people who challenge their  authority  the reform has been welcomed by  activists but there's been no  announcement  on when it will take effect